OK dans cette vidéo vous allez
comprendre ce qu'est réellement chat GPT
ce que permet cette intelligence
artificielle comment elle fonctionne
concrètement pourquoi certains
considèrent que c'est une révolution
tandis que d'autres considèrent que
c'est une menace et on va voir aussi les
concurrents qui arrivent pour tenter
déjà de la remplacer à noter que cette
vidéo est la première vidéo d'une petite
série qui arrive dédiée à ce sujet pour
mieux comprendre ce qui se joue
actuellement sous nos yeux du coup
pensez à vérifier et à vous abonner
évidemment si notre travail vous plaît
pour nous soutenir alors première
question rapidement que peut faire tchat
GPT chat GPT techniquement c'est un
chatbot donc un robot conversationnel
qui est basé sur une intelligence
artificielle et avec qui on peut
discuter ou alors demander des choses et
en fait on peut lui demander beaucoup de
choses un plan de dissertation ou même
une dissertation complète pour un sujet
de philosophie une lettre de motivation
pour rejoindre Hugo décrypte des idées
de cadeaux pour votre copain ou copine
alors que la Saint-Valentin approche ou
encore de l'aide pour coder quelque
chose en fait à peu près tout est
possible le seul petit frein ses
connaissances s'arrête à 2021 et là où
c'est intéressant c'est que ça un
dialogue donc vous pouvez lui demander
de préciser certains éléments de sa
première réponse par exemple pour la
Saint-Valentin vous pouvez préciser ce
qu'est ou non votre copine ou alors ce
que vous lui avez déjà offert par le
passé vous pouvez aussi demander de
tester une autre méthode de répondre
avec un certain style un certain format
une certaine longueur bref plus vous lui
parlez plus vous pouvez lui préciser et
lui demander de sortir ce dont vous avez
réellement besoin bref on va revenir
là-dessus juste après mais dans l'idée
c'est donc un robot avec qui vous pouvez
discuter et qui est à votre service y
compris pour des tâches techniques assez
complexes alors qui est derrière chat
GBT et bien c'est une société américaine
qui a été créée en 2015 qui s'appelle
open hey parmi ces co-fondateurs on
retrouve un certain Elon Musk alors Elon
Musk n'est pas tout seul sur cette
société très loin de là d'ailleurs il a
pris pas mal de distance ces dernières
années concernant le projet suite
notamment à des désaccords le nom à
retenir en fait c'est Sam Altman par
ailleurs le directeur du prestigieux
incubateur de start-up why combinator à
noter au passage qu'à l'origine openayai
c'était juste une organisation une asso
à but non lucratif mais c'est devenu une
entreprise à part entière en 2019 et
c'est un changement de méthode qui a été
pas mal critiqué par certains de leur
côté openay-y et samaltman le justifie
par un besoin et bien de lever les fonds
et de tenter de rentabiliser tout cela
pour continuer à progresser et à noter
aussi qu'aujourd'hui openay-y est aussi
à l'origine d'une autre intelligence
artificielle dont vous avez peut-être
entendu parler ces derniers mois il
s'agit de Dali jeux de mots entre le nom
du peintre Salvador Dali et le robot de
Pixar Wally c'est une niaque et donc
capable de créer des images à partir de
textes par exemple chez vous voulez un
panda chimiste jouant avec des produits
chimiques version art moderne et bien
voilà la version de Dali qui est générée
on aura l'occasion de parler de tout ça
dans une autre vidéo alors chat GPT a
été rendu accessible comme prototype le
30 novembre dernier et ça a été tout de
suite un énorme succès on a compté un
million d'utilisateurs en 5 jours ce qui
est absolument énorme petite élément de
comparaison voici le temps qu'il a fallu
à d'autres boîtes ou services
aujourd'hui mondialement connus pour
atteindre le même nombre d'utilisateurs
alors comment est-ce que tout cela
fonctionne bon déjà ça n'a rien à voir
avec les chatbots qui étaient là il y a
quelques années en 2018 par exemple
j'avais créé un chatbot sur Messenger et
vous étiez quelques dizaines de milliers
à suivre où je vous envoyais chaque jour
les actualités du jour c'est l'ancêtre
de ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui sur
Instagram notamment et sur ce chatbot
c'était très simple si vous disiez non
je veux pas d'actu vous envoyer pas les
actus à l'inverse mais vous cliquez sur
Oui je veux les actus du jour et bien je
vous envoyais les actus du jour même
chose pour le débat je vous l'envoyer
vous cliquez si oui ou non vous vouliez
participer au débat tout cela était pris
en compte c'était vraiment une interface
assez simpliste comme la plupart des
chatbots en fait à l'époque mais là en
l'occurrence avec check GPT c'est un
chatbot qui est très très différent
chaque GPT fonctionne avec ce que l'on
appelle un modèle de langage en anglais
on parle de lllm pour large langage
mordores en gros c'est des modèles qui
ont pour ambition d'imiter le langage
humain les premiers modèles de langage
date de 2017 vous avez déjà interagi
sans le savoir avec un modèle de langage
si par exemple un jour vous étiez en
train d'écrire un mail sur Gmail et
Gmail à automatiquement fini votre
phrase en vous proposant automatiquement
les derniers mots alors tchat GPT
fonctionne grâce à l'un des modèles les
plus performants au monde actuellement
c'est GPT trois points 5 c'est l'un des
modèles de l'entreprise donc open hei et
j'ai pété 3 et capable de faire beaucoup
plus que simplement compléter des bouts
de phrases vous l'aurez compris il peut
générer des textes entiers à partir de
ce que vous lui proposez ou à partir de
ce que vous lui demandez alors comment
ça fonctionne un modèle de langage
comment est-ce que une intelligence
artificielle comme ça peut construire
des phrases au fur et à mesure avec
quelques secondes d'attentes en gros
faut un peu imaginer ça comme un giga
ordinateur qui a absorbé une énorme
masse de texte écrit au départ par des
humains et ces textes ça peut être des
centaines de milliards de livres ou
alors des centaines de milliards de
textes publiés sur Internet et c'est à
partir en fait de cette matière que
cette intelligence artificielle va faire
ce que l'on appelle du Deep learning
donc de l'apprentissage profond et donc
cette quantité de données considérable
va l'aider tout simplement à mieux
comprendre et à mieux s'améliorer au fur
et à mesure pour tenter à terme de
reproduire donc le langage humain et
pour vous vendre un petit peu compte de
toute la quantité de données que ça
représente dites-vous que j'ai pété 3.5
à ingurgiter tout Wikipédia en anglais
et ça ce Wikipédia en anglais ça
représente seulement
0,6% des textes qu'il a appris alors que
vous voyez un peu la longueur des
articles Wikipédia parfois et le nombre
d'articles qui sont disponibles
autrement dit donc cette intelligence
artificielle a absorbé beaucoup beaucoup
de données ça c'est donc assez
classiquement et vraiment j'ai expliqué
très simplement le fonctionnement d'un
modèle de langage et ce n'est pas
spécifique en soi à chat GPT mais ce qui
fait précisément spécificité de chat GPT
c'est qu'on lui a rajouté ensuite à ça
des couches de contrôle de
l'entraînement en fait progressif avec
l'être humain pour lui apprendre à
générer donc non pas juste un texte
construit un peu robotique mais bien un
texte qui sonne bien à l'oreille humaine
autrement dit pour rendre la machine un
peu moins inhumaine entre guillemets et
bien il y a eu à cette étape avec une
vérification et un travail avec les
humains c'est ce que l'on appelle
l'apprentissage par renforcement
laning en anglais en gros les réponses
et le fonctionnement de chat GPT ont été
améliorés au fur et à mesure par des
retours d'êtres humains voilà donc pour
ce fonctionnement en deux étapes ce
qu'il faut donc bien comprendre pour
résumer c'est que quand vous lui posez
une question et bien chat GPT ne va pas
aller chercher la réponse sur Internet
elle va en fait chercher la réponse
directement dans ses propres données
qu'elle a enregistré au fur et à mesure
dans ces milliards de textes alors
justement quels sont les utilisations
potentielles je vous l'ai dit ça permet
énormément de choses et je pense qu'on
fera une vidéo dédiée montrer d'ailleurs
toutes les possibilités avec ce genre
d'intelligence artificielle on va
revenir là-dessus après mais ça peut
vous aider pour beaucoup de choses ça
peut vous aider pour résumer ou
synthétiser vos notes pour traduire très
facilement des documents pour générer un
plan sur un article ou alors vous
recommander et bien des lectures sur un
sujet précis que vous voulez creuser
bref ça permet beaucoup de choses pour
votre quotidien y compris d'ailleurs
pour des développeurs c'est là aussi
c'est intéressant de nombreux exemples
montrent à quel point vient un chat GPT
peut très facilement détecter une erreur
dans un code une faille de sécurité ou
alors corriger directement certaines
lignes de code à titre personnel là où
j'ai été pas mal bluffé c'est dans la
façon dont laquelle et bien ce côté
conversationnel pouvait permettre de
résoudre certaines choses je vais vous
donner un exemple très précis l'autre
jour je suis allé au cinéma je suis
sorti du cinéma je cherchais le terme ou
la notion qui définissait le fait que
dans un film et dans un scénario et bien
tout était présent pour une raison
précise parce qu'en général on
retrouvait tel ou tel objet plus tard
dans le film j'ai essayé donc de taper
ça sur Google et d'expliquer ce que je
cherchais sur Google sauf que Google ne
me trouvait pas tout simplement ce que
je cherchais et donc je me suis tourné
vers chat GPT j'ai expliqué comme ça
avec mes propres mots ce que je
cherchais est la notion que je cherchais
le tout en français au départ il a pensé
que la notion que je cherchais c'était
la notion de flashback je lui ai dit que
non c'est pas du tout ce que je
cherchais alors il a creusé il a fini
par me trouver ce que je cherchais à
savoir donc la notion de fusil de
Tchekhov et c'est une notion que j'avais
pas réussi à trouver aussi facilement
sur Google bref le côté conversationnel
un peu comme si on parlait à un humain
finalement peut aider dans ce genre de
situation on a des choses qui peuvent
paraître assez floues et on sait pas
forcément quel terme rentrer sur Google
enfin pour mesurer pleinement le
potentiel d'une intelligence
artificielle comme chat GPT il faut
comprendre le potentiel de la
combinaison qu'il peut avoir avec
d'autres outils d'intelligence
artificielle de cette façon donc tu as
GPT pourrait produire un texte et
ensuite et bien une synthèse vocale
voire un avatar pour et ensuite incarner
ce texte c'est un exemple parmi tant
d'autres de combinaisons d'IAS qui sont
aujourd'hui possibles
une notion à retenir c'est la notion de
prompt le prompt en fait c'est donc la
formule la phrase que vous entrez dans
une intelligence artificielle pour
qu'elle vous sorte la meilleure chose ce
qui arrive en fait aujourd'hui à bien
utiliser chat GPT ou même plus
généralement les différentes
intelligences artificielles qui sont
disponibles ce sont les personnes qui
arrivent à utiliser les bons termes et
les bonnes formulations pour être bien
compris par l'IA et donc avoir la
réponse la plus pertinente et la plus
précise et d'ailleurs en ligne
aujourd'hui on retrouve des sites qui
répertorient les bonnes formules à
connaître pour vous aider tout
simplement au quotidien alors est-ce que
tchat GPT peut remplacer certains
métiers là-dessus autant le dire tout de
suite voir des emplois menacés c'est
indéniablement un risque majeur comme
dans chaque révolution technique par
exemple quand Gutenberg a inventé
l'imprimerie au 15ème siècle et bien ça
a petit à petit signifié la fin des
moines copistes c'est moi qui recopiait
les textes pour en produire des nouveaux
exemplaires et là en l'occurrence les
technologies dérivées de modèles de
langage comme chat GPT on le potentiel
de bousculer tout un tas de secteurs à
commencer par exemple par le secteur du
marketing chaque GPT à la capacité de
bousculer complètement le métier de
rédacteur web ou alors de community
manager il peut vous écrire des dizaines
de postes Instagram en quelques secondes
vous écrire des dizaines d'articles pour
du référencement et SIO du référencement
sur les moteurs de recherche et certes
les résultats sont rarement parfaits
mais c'est souvent des bonnes premières
versions de la même façon l'intelligence
artificielle a le potentiel de
chambouler pas mal de métiers autour du
service client c'est vrai aussi pour
tous les métiers autour de la traduction
la traduction étant extrêmement propre
sur les dernières versions par exemple
de chat GPT et c'est vrai aussi pour
plein de métiers administratifs ou
juridique et c'est vrai enfin pour plein
de tâches dans le développement
informatique j'en parlais du coup à
l'instant c'est des choses qui sont
facilités et rendus beaucoup plus simple
avec des intelligences artificielles
bref oui beaucoup de métiers pourraient
être vous voulez cela dit il y a des
sceptiques qui estiment que chat GPT ou
les intelligences artificielles plus
généralement ne seront jamais capables
d'autres choses que des reproductions
mécaniques et que son absence d'esprit
critique de raisonnement ou alors de
conscience et d'éthique peuvent les
mener vite dans une forme d'impasse je
rentrerai en tout cas dans les détails
dans une autre vidéo sur cette chaîne
Youtube mais à priori les intelligences
artificielles détruiront des emplois et
en créeront aussi potentiellement des
nouveaux c'est le principe de la
destruction créatrice une notion qui a
été popularisée par l'économiste
Schumpeter là où ça se complique par
contre c'est que les emplois détruits
risquent d'être des emplois peu
qualifiés alors que les emplois créés
risquent d'être moins nombreux donc déjà
moins nombreux que les emplois détruits
mais aussi des emplois plus qualifiés
typiquement des personnes capables de
manier de telles technologies qui
nécessite donc des compétences
particulières tout ça pose donc un enjeu
plus large déjà sur notre rapport au
travail mais aussi sur la croissance
potentielle des inégalités est-ce ça
doit poser aussi en termes de modèles de
société et d'ailleurs ça pose des
questions plus larges sur une telle
intelligence artificielle la question du
besoin est-ce qu'on en a réellement
besoin la question de l'envie ou non
d'aller aussi vers de tel technologies
certains estiment que c'est inévitable
et que donc on a juste à voir le train
passé alors que d'autres estiment que
bien ce n'est pas forcément inévitable
et que c'est un choix de développer ou
non de tel technologie c'est donc un
sujet quasiment philosophique aussi qui
fait beaucoup débats alors maintenant
quels sont les limites de chat GPD alors
première limite assez majeure à la fois
chat GPT c'est beaucoup et en même temps
il ne sait pas grand chose en effet ces
données peuvent considérer comme étant
encore limité et puis au-delà de ça
malgré cet apprentissage progressif bien
chat GPT je le disais n'a pas d'esprit
critique et peut donc faire des erreurs
de synthèse si jamais vous l'avez testé
vous en avez très sûrement remarqué
vous-même ensuite c'est intéressant de
noter que l'apprentissage de chat GPT
c'est fait en partie via des textes
venus d'Internet sauf que je ne vous
apprends rien Internet et même
d'ailleurs les livres renferment aussi
certes des vérités mais aussi de
nombreux biais bref chat GPT peut donc
se tromper et vous donner soit des
mauvaises réponses soit et bien des
choses complètement biaisées pour
résumer chat GPT oui et complètement
capable de se tromper et finalement ça
arrive assez souvent d'ailleurs parfois
et bien il y a peut vous sortir des
bêtises complètes avec le ton et une
confiance assez étonnante et déroutante
d'ailleurs l'entreprise qui a créé open
II le reconnaît officiellement elle
affirme que chat GPT peut
occasionnellement générer des
informations incorrectes ou trompeuses
et d'ailleurs sur Twitter il y a des
exemples de personnes qui réalisent que
4G PPT raconte n'importe quoi ils lui
font donc remarquer et à ce moment-là le
robot leur répond que oui c'est vrai ce
qu'il a dit est complètement
erroné deuxième limite très rapidement
de chat GPT en tout cas dans sa version
actuelle n'est pas reliée à Internet en
fait son apprentissage est limité à une
certaine date en l'occurrence
aujourd'hui afin 2021 par exemple
aujourd'hui chat GPT n'est pas capable
de vous qui a remporté la Coupe du Monde
2022 parce qu'il a été configuré avant
ça à la limite moi ça me gêne pas ça me
permet d'oublier la défaite de 2022 et
en termes d'information forcément ça
pose beaucoup de questions cela dit tout
ça pourrait changer notamment avec les
prochaines versions de GPT 3gpt 4 du
coup qui vont être développés à l'avenir
c'est des systèmes qui devraient être
basés sur beaucoup plus de données y
compris du coup les données plus
récentes et ça amène donc un potentiel
assez important pour l'avenir autre
limite qu'on peut noter de chat GPT ça
c'est plus du côté d'openhaye mais en
fait aujourd'hui c'est un outil qui
n'est pas rentable en l'état et plus
qu'une limite en fait c'est une
interrogation qu'on peut se poser sur
l'évolution de ce robot là en effet
aujourd'hui c'est un outil qui est en
bêta donc qui est en phase de test et
qui est gratuit pour tout le monde
depuis le 30 novembre et vous l'aurez
peut-être remarqué je mets vous
l'utilisez vous-même il y a souvent en
fait un bug avec le site qui est
complètement fermé tout simplement parce
qu'il y a trop de monde qui essaient de
l'utiliser or tout cela coûte très cher
du côté d'openhaye de l'autre côté open
Yaye a bien conscience de tout ça et
l'entreprise a annoncé ce premier
février un abonnement payant pour
pouvoir utiliser tchat GPT même en
période de fortes demandes la formule
s'appelle tchat GPT plus et le prix a
été fixé pour l'instant à 20 dollars par
mois alors ça c'est pour les limites
mais maintenant je voulais aussi qu'on
voit les différents risques associés à
une telle intelligence artificielle en
effet avec chat GPT vient indéniablement
le risque de voir émerger des fausses
informations à grande échelle des
personnes mal intentionnées pourraient
par exemple produire des faux articles
de presse que des gens pourraient
prendre pour vrai et les produire donc
massivement pour les diffuser sur les
réseaux sociaux autre questionnement
majeurs qui entoure chat GPT plus
largement d'ailleurs toutes les
intelligences artificielles basées sur
des modèles de langage plusieurs experts
s'inquiètent sur les biais
potentiellement racistes ou sexistes qui
serait donc susceptibles d'entretenir
des stéréotypes pourquoi et bien parce
que je viens de le dire saisias sont
entraînés par des humains mais à partir
de textes qui sont déjà établis or ces
textes qui viennent d'Internet ou de
livres ils peuvent eux aussi des biais
des biais et des erreurs qui pourraient
être donc reproduites à travers ces
intelligences artificielles là-dessus en
tout cas c'est un problème sur lequel
openia il travaille en ce moment on
verra donc s'ils arrivent à résoudre ces
problèmes pour les prochaines versions
de ces intelligences artificielles autre
critique qui est adressée à chat GPT
c'est le fait qu'il ne présente pas
aujourd'hui ses sources ne dit pas en
fait quel texte il a utilisé pour écrire
tel ou telle réponse ça pose forcément
de questions déjà une question de
pouvoir vérifier les informations
nous-mêmes pour vérifier si ce que dit
chat GPT est vrai ou faux mais aussi un
problème concernant les droits ça pose
donc des questions importantes en
matière de droits d'auteur à qui
appartiennent finalement les textes
qu'il génère la question se pose de la
même façon pour les images générées par
des intelligences artificielles comme
Dali par exemple l'Américain Jason Allen
qui a remporté le premier prix d'art
numérique à la foire de l'État du
Colorado avec cette image créée par Liam
midjorni cette image est-ce qu'elle
appartient à celui qui a tapé les bonnes
commandes sur une intelligence
artificielle est-ce qu'elle appartient
plutôt à l'intelligence artificielle ou
est-ce qu'elle appartient à tous les
auteurs finalement dont ce sont inspirés
cette IA pour générer cette image je
rentre pas dans tous les détails ici
sinon ça va durer très longtemps mais
c'est un débat qui agite beaucoup en ce
moment les juristes la question du droit
d'auteur et de sa remise en cause avec
l'intelligence artificielle très
rapidement aussi il faut noter qu'une
telle intelligence artificielle pose
aussi des questions sur la façon dont
l'éducation se fait aujourd'hui en effet
de plus en plus d'étudiants et bien
utilisent tchat GPT pour générer des
plantes dissertation voir des
dissertations directement avec une IA or
certaines écoles comme par exemple
Sciences Po Paris il y a quelques jours
ont annoncé l’interdiction d'utiliser de
telles outils pour faire des travaux à
la maison par exemple d'autres à
l'inverse estiment que c'est une
révolution assez inévitable que de la
même façon que Internet a été d'une aide
importante pour travailler avec
Wikipédia avec des recherches très
faciles et bien de tels doivent aussi
être utilisés c'est un gros débat au
quotidien y compris sur du coup ce qui
doit être appris à l'université après
tout à quoi bon finalement apprendre par
cœur certains éléments apprendre
certaines méthodes quand tout cela peut
être disponible directement sur un tel
outil d'ailleurs openéi a fait une
grosse annonce là-dessus ce mardi 31
janvier l'entreprise est en train de
développer un nouvel outil pour
permettre de distinguer justement les
textes écrits par l'homme des textes
écrits par chat GBT ou plus largement
d'ailleurs par les différentes
intelligences artificielles bref
beaucoup de questions parfois
controversées sur ce qui doit être
appris ou non à l'école et son évolution
potentielle là-dessus de la même façon
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler dans
une vidéo dédiée c'est un sujet qui me
semble assez essentiel je vais pas
rentrer dans tous les détails
aujourd'hui on aura l'occasion d'en
parler pour terminer il faut quand même
noter que l'ambition même de chat GPT
fait beaucoup débats en effet chat GPT
c'est l'ambition de ce qu'on appelle une
intelligence artificielle générale sont
ces répondre à tous les problèmes tous
les sujets un peu quasiment comme un
dieu ou un demi dieu et c'est une
ambition jugée dangereuse par certains
là aussi on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler sur ces grands débats qui
animent et bien artificielle et les
sujets d'éthiques en tout cas il faut
noter que tchat GPT ce n'est qu'une
version bêta une version de test et Open
hey promet une nouvelle version beaucoup
beaucoup plus puissante dans les
prochains mois basé sur un nouveau
modèle de langage appelé gpt4 enfin un
Microsoft a déjà aujourd'hui investi
massivement de openéi on parle de plus
de 10 milliards de dollars investis ça
va donc être intéressant de voir comment
Microsoft va rattacher chat GPT à ces
outils déjà existants et justement ce
mardi 7 février microsoft a annoncé
officiellement que tchat GPT allait être
intégré à son moteur de recherche Bing
l'objectif donc c'est de tenter de faire
revenir Bing et son navigateur Edge dans
la course face à Google Google qui a
très clairement pris le dessus ces
dernières années et par ailleurs il faut
aussi noter que d'autres intelligences
artificielles se développent par ce par
là en parallèle Google par exemple
travaille à sa propre intelligence
artificielle avec notamment sa société
appelée deep mind et deep mind travail
en ce moment un projet de chatbot un peu
similaire à chat GPT qui s'appelle pour
l'instant Sparrow et donc une version
bêta pourrait sortir fin 2023 et
justement Eagle a annoncé le lancement
très prochainement de son concurrent à
tchat GPT qui va s'appeler barde barde
devrait être lancé en test au grand
public dans les semaines à venir et à la
différence de chat GPT il pourrait déjà
être relié à Internet pour pouvoir donc
fournir des réponses sur des événements
récents Google a notamment publié un
visuel qui laisse penser que des
réponses de cette IA pourrait être
intégrées en haut de certaines
recherches sur son moteur de recherche
on verra donc ce qu'il en est j'espère
en tout cas que cette vidéo vous aura
permis d'y voir plus clair si c'est le
cas pensez à vous abonner pour permettre
à la chaîne de continuer à se développer
et surtout nous soutenir sachant que
d'autres vidéos arrivent directement sur
ce sujet dans les prochaines semaines
directement sur la chaîne merci en tout
cas pour votre confiance je suis
conscient que c'est une première vidéo
très large on a abordé plein de sujets
différents donc précisera sur certains
sujets dans les prochains jours
n'hésitez pas je faisais des questions
d'ailleurs directement dans les
commentaires on y répondra du coup dans
les prochaines vidéos